hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the secretive Pineview
forest now take yourself back a long
long way back hello hi can I help you
okay bye
have a good day lady anyway take
yourselves back to a game called passing
Pineview forest this is another game in
the same series all in relation to
Pineview drive which is a game that was
released that was met with mixed
expectations much likely both of these
games here but this is a free addition
to the game that's supposed to serve as
a prequel to the new the new game that's
going to be coming out try and disclose
the secret of Pineview force I don't
know if I want to I don't know if that's
exactly a choice I have considering that
my car blew up here I believe all wives
hello Oh Chris fo alright okay so at
least I got a flashlight so that's kind
of good but oh my god I am slow oh good
I can run oh hey hey yeah ah I can't get
over it
laughs oh hey that's probably not a good
idea to stand near as we wander into the
forest I can't help but be reminded as
is whenever I play an indie horror game
taking place in a forest I cannot help
but be reminded of Slenderman even
though I know that this game has
absolutely nothing to do with that and
there's absolutely no chance that
there's any Slender men inside these
forests all I know is that there's
something lurking in the darkness
oh hi what's that oh it's a deer oh hi
Oh spooked it Oh spooked it okay bye
alright looks like the exact same deer
from the rake the multiplayer game I
played with Wade and Bob probably don't
even
well lightning and thunder and it's a
clear day night whatever oh hi again
welcome back you come to say hi can I
sneak out nope hmm it doesn't like me
doesn't like me at all
I don't know why I'm a nice guy oh boy
oh oh good I'm gonna assume that's bears
I'm gonna assume that's bears mating cuz
it's bear mating season out in the woods
I don't know if that's gonna bode well
for me
depends on how attractive I am to bears
okay
beginning to less and less think that
that's actually bears beginning to more
think that might be deathly death on the
way it better be my shadow on the ground
like again I I must question the Thunder
but I'm also hearing oh hi hello that's
odd why is there cottage here [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] hi okay
that's fine just owls for birds hi sorry
maybe I shouldn't go towards the gunshot
okay is that good bad is it good or bad
number one why is there a house right
here in the middle of the forest with no
roads to go into it and number two why
am i walking towards a house with a
blinking light in the window and number
three why am I going to I should
probably not go towards there that
sounded like it came close oh hi oh okay
sir are you aware of the gunshots from
that house oh okay yeah okay I'm gonna
assume against my better judgement here
and go into the building from whence
that guy is calmly walking away from
after the gunshots and whatnot
once that guy's gonna come back don't
know I want to want to go in here
well that's not good all right bye have
a lovely day oh no oh no oh no oh it's
never a good sign when you hear of rope
oh no oh no no I don't like this I don't
like this in any way
easy back is he back okay ye Oh what is
that what is that I got stuck on the
stairs for a second there is that the
Blair Witch thing whoa okay alright well
that was a whole lot of nothing but I
got a key so that's good I'm so glad
yeah
yeah hitting my head on this okay
correct then
I swear I heard footsteps out here like
I'm not mistaken about that am i was
that dude that was just walking away oh
so calmly also there seems to be one
more level up just like a strange attic
for no reason but I've got a key
whatever the hell this key can go to no
idea let's try to skedaddle our way
through here there's actually kind of
nice just taking my time walking very
slowly through this game just trying to
explore the forest but I guess I might
as well hurry up or else I'm probably
gonna die the noises are getting louder
I don't know if that's all just in my
head or actually in the game and I'm
going to die okay ah okay
ah good yes well that's lovely that is
hey [ __ ] [ __ ] off some more birds was
that actually something
oh I see something hello hi it's not the
gun [ __ ] stop with the birds birds are
okay stop being scared of me and I'll
stop being scared of you Oh No Oh what
is this and why is this out here and who
maintains power to this light it's my
primary concern out here no one's gonna
come out and change this goddamn light
who lives here
there's no path no way oh okay well I'll
righty then
okay all righty then well I'll just
ignore the automatically closing wooden
gate go towards us weird hey looking
structure whoo there's something in the
underbrush I see you the [ __ ] is that
Watson oh is the other thing okay well
alright then nevermind I'm an idiot
hi Birds yeah nothing bad about that
just birds birds nothing to it nothing
to
so yeah I don't think anything this
force is actually gonna kill me so I
think I'll be okay well what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] hi hello King we doin out
here in the middle of the woods
your statue ass thing mad everything
else has been relatively normal here's a
little campfire can't light it on fire
whoa hello again alright again nothing
out of the ordinary here okay wait oh I
knew I heard something you dear bastard
get out of here I thought something
deadly was actually after me yep I knew
I saw something
it's another statue why is this is the
Queen why are there just these giant
obelisk Easter Egg Island statues here
that's so weird
dear friend I think that's just a deer
again maybe I just feel like I'm
wandering in circles but I'm pretty sure
I'm going down [ __ ] stop
stop it dear friend dear friend
dear friend that better have been you
dear friend Birds anything alright okay
I'll even take the king and queen
statues very then I don't know just feel
like I'm wandering towards a dead end
here
not that the woods could ever be a dead
end real life to kind of wander forever
until you eventually had either an ocean
a mountain or civilization or or death
by bears
oh geez it's another gate where am I now
you're even away through this what is
that oh and where did that guy go whoa
a horse [ __ ] stop
the [ __ ] is that the [ __ ] is that dead
deer
it better be dear friend that dear
friend yeah get out of here dear friend
dear [ __ ] spoofing me in the dark
like that woman buy a horse heat all
right hello horsie how you doing good to
see you
you stay safe out there you don't know
what kind of monsters are lurking and I
don't know what kind of person has a
farm out here like this
well maybe this is typical but nothing
I've seen before dear friend if dear
friend could stop spooking me for just
two seconds I'd be very happy in my life
hello what is that what is that what is
that it looks like a door why would
there be a door out here how would there
be anything out here okay all right then
maybe secret underground bunker
carved into the mountain face it seems
likely oh it is a secret underground
bunker carved into the mountain face
who knew oh why don't have another
[ __ ] key god damn it I don't know
where to get another goddamn key [ __ ]
alrighty then I got to go back and
either maybe the horse had a key and I
gotta kill the horse you oh hey whoa
hi didn't notice you before this may be
where the crows kind of jump off from
yeah but I definitely didn't notice the
giant dead tree in the middle of the
place but there's gotta be like if I can
overlook a building like that there's
got to be something else that I've
overlooked back but I'm now back up
before the horse area there's gotta be
something else
whoa hi dear friend are you guiding me
are you warning me I don't know which I
should be more afraid of but one or the
other
hi hello how did I miss you how did I
miss this
oh man that's cool and also dumb of me
but that's actually kind of cool that
this game does have such a large map
that it's easy to overlook something as
big as this as lit up as this if you
don't explore how do you expect to get
anywhere in the game and that just makes
sense oh there's more Blair Witch stuff
good stop whoa found the depository of
all the burbs
No so there's gotta be something obvious
most of these doors whoa what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] did you see that is
that just me there's a goddamn fly on my
screen the [ __ ] was that what the [ __ ]
was that that was weird
toes really weird what the [ __ ] oh here
oh oh good I have an axe oh I can axe
anything a questionaire one oh god good
I can't tell if that's good but maybe I
can use this to break the lock now god
damn it that fly it's back the [ __ ] is
that I've never seen that that's
actually really weird cuz it
legitimately looks like it's on my
screen it legitimately looks like it's
on your screen have you guys been
noticing that and been like where's the
[ __ ] did that fly come from and I
haven't said anything that's [ __ ]
weird okay but I got an axe and I
checked out pretty much everything in
that little I don't know office whatever
you want to call that so I'm assuming
that this is what I'm gonna use to be
able to bash open the lock oh [ __ ]
goddamn it dear friend I will axe you in
the ass that is up that is a very rude
response to my obviously illegitimate
claim you can't take these things too
seriously dear friend I'm not really
gonna ask you in the ass actually the
face but on the ass
oh Jesus it's better here because if
it's not then I have no idea what I'm
supposed to be doing cuz if this isn't
it and I don't know yes okay good
maybe oh this seems bad oh it seems the
opposite of good oh oh oh no and yes my
flashlights on it's just freaking dark
there's something at the end of the
hallway
my friend you want to be my friend
friend are you a friend friend well I
see a dark shadowy figure at the end of
them hi oh oh no my flashlight turned
off oh you won't turn back on I see you
I'm coming at Jeff yeah oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy that's
something oh boy oh boy okay it's gone
now oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
Oh goddammit get out of here fly [ __ ]
fly bastard oh [ __ ] [ __ ] don't
[ __ ] with me
don't dick with me where am I now
hi hello you look shook can I help you
okay that's not working okay good no
okay that works
Oh Oh lovely lovely this is what lovely
decor oh well I got a key I'm assuming
okay okay all right didn't want to use
that one anyway oh I got a key hi
[Music]
I can't move cut [ __ ] hell
god damn it well that was a weird thing
to walk into you can't blame me you have
been playing the secret of time view
force not bad not bad at all there are a
lot of good things in this game and they
did end on a solid note I will say that
but it's gotta be careful because the
openness of the forest was very good but
without enough diversity in the forest
it can rapidly become boring but they
had a lot of good things going on in
this force I love the open realm
investigation you'll find things or
maybe you won't find things the only
problem with that is if you require
something to be found there's gonna be a
lot of lost wandering around you're
literally just gonna be going back and
forth which is what happened to me I
ended up going backwards and forward a
few time before I found that axe um but
other than that there's a lot of good
elements here it's had some good spooks
it had some good atmosphere to it the
graphics were top-notch not top-notch
but good enough um and then like that
ending hallway was a good bit because I
didn't know if I actually saw something
until I was right on top of it but I had
a good idea so again a lot of good
elements here and for a free game oh I'm
on this list hey yay I'm on here so a
lot of good things but you know could be
refined a bit more but still good so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I wonder when this full game is gonna
come out I'm gonna check out the
Kickstarter over there but either way
thank you again everybody from wool hi
well that's creepy
all righty then actually I'm gonna get
to the end of the credits first okay
seems like that might have been it if
that Scarecrow is in the game then again
they have another game called pond view
drive that is another version of the
game that came out a couple years ago
that I have not played but if that
scarecrow characters in it and he's
sufficiently scary that could be a good
game but either way that seems to be it
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
ah
[Music]
Kludd
you